the Regional Transportation Commission
wants you to be safe on board
acknowledging more needs to be done to
ensure Safety and Security while riding
Madison Kimbrough joining us live near
the transit center on Bonneville and
Casino Center Boulevard joining us now
with more Madison
this downtown location is one of the
busiest bus stops across the valley and
with large numbers of passengers
problems can arise easily so the RTC
leaders are aware of this and increasing
security
with incident numbers on the rise the
RTC is making major strides to protect
its drivers and passengers with the help
of a budget increase this year this
being discussed at this month's board
meeting quit doing surveys start putting
boots on the ground get your staff out
on buses or looking in on the video
camera that increase in budget has
allowed for more Security on buses with
over 200 active officers compared to the
initial 185. some positive news with
more security RTC reports violent acts
on drivers are down by 18 percent with
Plexiglas enclosures added due to the
pandemic the RTC has found that having
those barriers up continuously has
helped deter driver assault but as for
passenger safety there's a lot more work
that needs to be done according to RTC
Deputy CEO Francis Julian the number of
assaults actually went up by um 20 what
we have to take in consideration our
ridership as well has gone after uh
drastically we're back probably to 80 of
the prefolded numbers so in in terms of
ridership the passengers who take the
bus daily say they are fully aware of
some Behavior troubles that can be on
the buses but they do feel secure in
their day-to-day rides it's just a
normal thing you see fights and most of
the time you don't really see nothing
with the bus driver it'd just be people
among themselves maybe somebody bumped
them on accident you got to keep your
eyes open all the time never initiate a
conversation never stare at anybody
and as for which buses get security
officers on board that all depends on
data and where the most incidents occur
reporting live in Downtown Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now